drivers nationwide may have noticed gas
prices are dropping after hitting a
record of five dollars and two cents
back in june six weeks later the average
is four dollars and 36 cents for a
gallon of regular that is of course
still very high but it's not the only
thing that is helping travelers if you
are headed to europe the dollar is now
the strongest it's been against a euro
for two decades as remy and asensio
shows us that means it might be a good
time to travel overseas
welcome to oxford street this is
london's most famous shopping street and
europe's biggest the u.s dollar is now
about 15 percent stronger than the
british pound and the euro in the past
year
like many u.s tourists retirees
catherine and bruce from detroit are on
a european tour we're still looking at
bags and scarves bags and scarves maybe
a little tiny modest piece of jewelry
and the fact that we're going to paris
next is nice and that the euro has
crashed now is the best time to come to
europe emma hazlitt is a business
journalist at the uk's new statesman
it's just
cheaper
to buy stuff over here so if you're
going to come to uk like you can visit
our amazing restaurants and we have a
hospitality sector that was absolutely
destroyed by the pandemics and they are
desperate to welcome you in
like recent u.s high school grads olivia
and valentino from los angeles
right now is the perfect opportunity to
go to europe we expected prices to be a
lot higher and they were quite a bit
lower so we're having a really good time
out here yeah the euro hasn't been this
week against the u.s dollar in two
decades now one dollar just about equals
one euro
which means in paris your morning
croissant and espresso for three euro
fifty would cost you three dollars and
fifty cents last year you would have
paid a buck more
in rome your double scoop gelato for
five euro yes will run you five bucks
last year 6 50 to stay cool in the heat
and here in london's west end a ticket
to harry potter costs an average 85
pounds this time last year that was
about 110 dollars this year about a
hundred
to be sure you have to get to europe
first and airfares are soaring because
of higher fuel costs
prices between new york and paris for
example have tripled since march 2019
and average hotel prices in europe are
up 44 in the past year some of europe's
hottest destinations pushing 250 bucks a
night
but if you can't get away just yet you
have time
for the british pound and the euro
what's the forecast some people are
saying it's going to hold fairly steady
but there's others that are saying that
it's really going to drop it's almost as
if you're saying uh one man's misery is
another man's happiness
yes absolutely and that means you still
have time to buy those plane tickets and
to get over here sure they are more
expensive than normal but we've met a
lot of americans who already have
raymond ascencio cbs news london